Salut! Il y a quelques jours,  je vous ai proposé sur Facebook, de participer à la prochaine vidéo, à cette vidéo.
Le but étant que je mentalise l'un ou l'une d'entre vous en faisant un tirage au sort
Quoi qu'il se passe, je garderai la vidéo.
Vous avez été 111 aujourd'hui à répondre à mon post sur facebook,
donc, je vais générer 2 chiffres de manière aléatoire entre 1 et 111.
2, parce que, si la première personne n'est pas disponible pour le faire, j'aurai déjà mon deuxième.
"Générer"
Et le résultat est 56 ou 27, donc je vais prendre le 56ième.
Et la 56ième personne à avoir posté un commentaire pour participer, c'est Emma.
*sonnerie skype*
Ce petit son de skype.
Vous savez qu'avant, je n'utilisais pas skype du tout.
Emma : Salut!
Fabien : Hey, salut Emma!
F : Ecoute, je suis en train de changer d'opérateur téléphonique et je n'ai quasi plus internet, en fait.
Emma : Ah. Non, comme ça, moi je n'ai pas de problème, là.
F: Tu vois, moi, c'est... c'est un petit peu dur à l'image, mais bon, écoute, si toi tu me vois bien et que tu m'entends bien, ça me va.
F : Merci Emma en tout cas d'avoir participé. T'as quel âge? T'as 15 ans, 16 ans, un truc comme ça?
E: Euh, je vais avoir 16 ans là, cet été, ouais.
F : 16 ans cet été. T'es de quoi, fin juillet, fin août?
E : Ouais, le 25 juillet.
F : Une petite lionne?
E : C'est ça.
F : Ok, ça roule
F : Je t'ai envoyé, je t'ai envoyé tout à l'heure un... Un lien vers une bibliothèque photo sur internet.
E : Ouais, ouais, je l'ai.
F : T'es allée voir un peu les photos, c'est pas 50 fois la même?
E : Vite fait, j'ai regardé le lien, j'ai ouvert, j'ai un petit peu tourné, mais pas plus.
F : Oui, c'était juste histoire que tu vois qu'il n'y a pas 50x la même photo, sinon, ça n'aurait pas trop d'intérêt.
F : Alors, l'idée c'est que je vais essayer de savoir quelle photo toi tu vas choisir.
F : Donc, le but du jeu, c'est que tu choisisse une photo, tu fais défiler les photos et tu t'arrêtes sur celle que tu décides de prendre toi.
E : OK
F : Tu me dis quand c'est bon. Tu peux prendre tout le temps que tu veux.
E : D'accord.
F : Moi, je couperai après au montage, si je veux.
F : Alors, il faut que... Il faut que je trouve déjà grosso modo, en fait, tu vois, une espèce de tunnel, un chemin pour resserrer.
F : Je ne te cache pas que les 50 photos, je suis allé les voir moi aussi. Tu vois, je sais à peu près quel pannel c'est.
F : Néanmoins, si je pouvais trouver sur quelle photo tu t'es arrêtée en deux, trois questions, là, ce serait top.
F : Je ne sais pas si c'est possible. Surtout... Alors, je sais déjà que tu es une lionne, donc, tu es quelqu'un qui a du tempérament, donc tu devrais prendre quelque chose d'assez fort.
F : Et tu fais oui, donc c'est oui. OK! Juste en ne me disant que "oui" ou que "non", est ce qu'il y a une couleur principale qui se dégage?
E : Euuuh, oui.
F : Oui. D'accord, c'est intéressant.
F : Le "euuuh, oui", ça veut dire que, potentiellement, ça doit être de nuit ou qu'il y a beaucoup de noir, parce que tu as hésité sur le fait qu'il y avait 2 couleurs ou pas.
F : Donc je pense que c'est quelque chose d'assez bicolore. Il doit y avoir du noir et une couleur principale, je me trompe ou pas ?
E : Non, c'est ça.
F : OK. Tu peux prendre un des objets ou une des choses que tu vois à l'image et te concentrer sur ce mot-là.
F : Si, par exemple, il y a, je vais dire une bêtise mais, je vais dire un footballeur avec un ballon et des buts, tu peux penser à "ballon" ou à "footballeur", tu vois?
F : Est-ce que tu peux penser à un des mots de la photo?
E : OK.
F : Est-ce que tu peux penser à la première lettre du mot auquel tu penses?
E : Oui.
F : Oui. Tu me regardes dans les yeux. Enfin, "dans les yeux", tu me regardes dans la webcam, tu penses à cette lettre et tu ne cherches pas à me donner d'indice.
E : OK.
F : Ca peut être : A B C D E F G H I J K L. Je l'ai passé, on est d'accord?
E : Oui
F : Oui, ok. J'hésite entre deux. J'hésite entre celle que j'ai entourée, c'est celle sur laquelle j'hésite le plus, et sinon, j'ai une petite réaction sur celle que je n'entoure pas.
F : A quelle lettre tu pensais?
E : A "B".
F : A "B", ah, ben, tu vois, j'ai bien fait de marquer les deux.
F : J'ai hésité avec le "F" et j'avais une réaction sur le  "B". Quand tu verras la vidéo, tu verras que tu as cligné des yeux en plein sur le "B",
F : alors, du coup, je ne savais pas trop. Et sur le "F", pareil.
E : Ohlala.
F : C'est terrible à vivre, hein?
E : En plus, encore plus de le voir là, pas à travers les vidéos mais quand c'est toi qui le fais, c'est ...
F : "B", ça peut être plein de choses. Le mot auquel tu penses, ça peut être un mot, ne me dis rien, ça peut être un mot court, ça peut être un mot long,
F : ça peut représenter quelque chose d'abstrait, quelque chose de très concret, quelque chose qu'on a l'habitude de voir chez soi ou à l'extérieur.
F : Ok, c'est à l'extérieur
E : *rires*
F : C'est quoi, c'est du bois?
F : Ok, et je pense que l'image que tu as en tête, c'est du bois avec plein de feu par au-dessus, dans la nuit.
E : C'est ça.
F : C'est ça? Oui! J'étais un peu long, mais j'ai réussi quand même.
F : Ah, ouais, super, fais le voir, comme ça on aura même l'image. Yes!
E : Voilà.
F : Merci beaucoup! Comme quoi, ça valait le coup de lâcher un petit com'.
E : Voilà. En plus, d'habitude, je ne suis pas trop chanceuse dans ce chose, je n'y joue pas trop, mais là, je me suis dit "aller".
F : T'as un petit accent, t'es d'où, t'es du Sud, Montpellier, Nîmes?
E : J'ai un peu le nez bouché aussi, mais je suis de Nîmes.
F : Ah de Nîmes? Cool.
F : Tu fais quoi dans la vie?
E : Je suis lycéenne.
F : T'es au lycée, ben oui, je suis bête. 15 ans, je suis docteur chirurgien.
E : C'est les vacances, mais, sinon, je vais au lycée.
E : Mais, je suis bluffée, mais même à travers toutes les vidéos, toujours plus bluffée, mais là, encore mieux quand c'est moi qui... Enfin qand c'est toi qui travaille sur moi.
E : Je trouve ça encore plus bluffant.
F : Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo avec Emma et moi. Si ça vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à nous laisser un double pouce en l'air.
F : Non, pas un double, parce que sinon, ça va annuler le pouce. Donc, un pouce en l'air, c'est bien.
F : Vous pouvez nous laisser un petit commentaire, ça fait plaisir. Je les lis tous et je suis sûre qu'Emma va les lire.
F : Soyez gentils avec Emma!
F : Je vous surveille.
F : D'ici quelques jours, je vais vous annoncer également la FAQ que je fais pour les 30000.
F : Je vais peut-être la faire sur Snapchat, je ne sais pas trop. Dites moi dans les commentaires là où vous voulez qu'on la fasse.
F : Passez un excellent week-end, parce que demain, c'est le week-end. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir et rendez-vous demain à 11h, Ciao!